councillor auburn thank you very much
for attending tonight uh
and it's over to you
right thank you chairman good evening
members and uh anybody else who's
listening
or watching and uh thank you thank you
for the
invite and more than happy to
advise the os on
on what has happened during the summer
and we have a little presentation for
you
sorry sorry counselor can everybody see
that presentation
just as an introduction chair
uh obviously members will know
that uh it was quite um a different kind
of summer season
uh from out from our normal
type of seasons because of the
um sudden introduction from the
uh prime prime minister during covid
to tell people that they can go to the
beaches
and uh and because of the great weather
that
that we'd had um we basically got
blasted
and so this is to tell you
to show you how we managed why we
introduce the beach management plan
and the way forward that we believe is
the right thing
um so as as this as the first slide
says uh this briefing is to inform you
of the update of
the beach management plan and uh
and whilst the council launched the
beach management plan
in june following feedback from local
residents
and to help members of the public to
enjoy
our area in a safe environment
the plan saw the implementation of
additional cleansing resources over
the and above the usual uh
amount that we normally have in us in a
summer season
which included the introduction of more
bins than normal
uh reopening of all coastal toilets
although that was done in a phased
opening
a lot of enforcement activity and
uh and the return of the rnli coast
coast guards
um if i could have the next slide please
nick
uh as previously said the uh
many of uh our coastal resources not
just annie which saw a sharp
increase in the amount of people heading
to our beaches obviously as
as going abroad wasn't an option
and following the government's easing of
the restrictions
together with the high temperatures as
i've just said uh
caused us some real serious problems
um
having visitors to our area is obviously
an important part of our local economy
uh
puts in a hell of a lot of money into
our
area and keeps our businesses operating
although the majority of people who came
down
were quite responsible responsible the
numbers
that were on our beaches at times uh
was quite vast
and no social distancing was a was
observed
and also there were a lot of incidents
of irresponsible act activity
which included dangerous parking
there was there was fights on the
beaches
pardon the pun there uh but there was
also um
they left large volumes of litter uh and
anti-social behavior etc
um as the season when went on
it was clear that we needed a plan a
plan of action
and the beach management plan was uh
introduced
and delivered uh
via a weekly operation plan
and that that included discussions with
our partners stakeholders
and ongoing analysis of the situation
across our beaches on
on a weekly basis next please nick
as i just said we we joined forces with
other agencies
uh to help us deliver
the beach management plan those agencies
as you can see with the rnli
kemp police your leisure uh southeastern
trains
british transport police kent county
council and nhs
amongst others next slide please
the key actions from the beach
management plan
well weekly operational orders which
were shared with all the relevant
officers and partners
and sharing the key details of the
action plans in place
now this included the introduction of a
new beach supervisor who works at
weekends
afternoon shifts
and also on busy weekdays to pick up on
issues
that were quickly arising and to be able
to deal with them
and to get the right people in in the
right place
um we also it was a challenge to
uh oh hello
are we i'll be back now nick all right
um okay we're back again
yeah thank you
um
security was introduced uh
on the key on the key beaches my gate
rounds going
broadstairs as uh patrolling the areas
to ensure that the public were getting
the right
information and to guide them
into the best behavior possible possible
um it was uh
difficult at times people had barbecues
on the beaches bonfires
cycling on a promenade um
and even shellfish harvest and
harvesting
by large groups of people
um joining up
the supervisor security and uh
enforcement officers uh with our cctv
team to share information
and tackle the problems that were that
we were notified of
in in a quick time such as parking
obstruction
on a promenade slipways jet ski
launching etc
and also all that information
was shared with uh with their other
agencies
i think it's important at this point to
say
that uh some of why we basically
introduced the
security personnel
was uh our
members of staff in who were operating
our toilets were
threatened on a num on a number of
occasions
um and i
instructed that should that continue
that we close those those down because
obviously our first uh
instance should should be our protection
of our members of
staff luckily enough that didn't happen
as
as things quietened down and our
security goals that
that we employed did their job very very
very well
next slide please nick
okay um the key actions from the beach
management plan
was dealing with the ongoing problems
and trying to design them
out for instance putting barriers and
bollards
uh in places to stop people parking on
slipways
blocking emergency accesses uh and
non-permitted launching of watercraft
mainly the
jet skis which were proven to be a
problem
we also introduced new signage on bylaws
for the public
booklets booklets and businesses and
stakeholders
proactive communication messages were
put out you
may well have seen the um the boards
the electronic boards on the way into
than it which was advising members as
the
public as they were coming in uh what
beaches were full
especially botany bay which seemed to be
proved to be one of the most um visited
beaches and causing the most
problems um we'd linked up
with uh london borough councils
uh which meant that our messages have
been shared
with a far wider audience
we use regional media who broadcast our
messages on an hourly news bulletins
also helping to target people who are
coming to than it
from outside our area
we also were lucky enough to be
successful
in our use of the national media who did
share our key messages uh
myself and uh councillor everett
did several uh broadcast news news
broadcast
over various issues during the summer
especially in relation to the to toilet
provision um next slide please
so what was the next steps that we
decided
to do was to refresh our coastal signage
using graphics images
codes an example of better ways to
convey important information
uh we introduced a summary poster of our
bylaws
temporarily this summer or that summer
which can be seen around the bay still
communications plan will be devised
to proactively educate visitors and
residents on our new rules
uh targeting people before arrival
and during their time on our beaches and
utilizing our best practices
from around other areas including the
whole world so i'm told
and behaviour change the theory is to
ensure the way that we can communicate
this effectively
next slide please nick
right a review of operational presence
on our coast
and changes to staffing arrangements put
in place accordingly
an operational beach supervisor is
needed to work
thursday to monday to really manage the
coast seven days a week tackling
enforcement issues over the busiest
times
uh a general operational works and
maintenance
to design our anti-social behavior such
as barriers bollards and railings as
i've said before
floor markings have already started
the new coastal trail cycle markings
have been put
in place and positive feedback has been
received
we're also looking at changes to the
water user group
including some amendments through fees
and charges to reduce misuse of this
system
which has less to led to numerous issues
with barriers and jet skis this season
or
last season new slide please nick
a more formalized uh multi-agency
beach management partnership with
scheduled pre
and post-season meetings is already
underway
and that includes east east kent council
beach managers
police community units
coast guard and they are an elia we also
looking to reinstate
a reinstatement of our beach business
group network
meetings are planned over winter and
support for the tourism team to help
coordinate this
there is close working with our estates
team on improving
offerings and opportunities along the
coast and provide facilities in area
that are becoming busier for instance
botany bay also to manage existing
concessions more
more closely closer working
is is needed with the enforcement team
especially the education enforcement
officer
to team up on joint initiatives next
slide please nick
uh i think the one of the important
things i think that came out of it for
me was that
to ensure that uh we work more closely
with
existing community groups
uh we are currently working with a
community group in margate called rise
up
clean up uh which is it to introduce
12 tiny pack litter bag dispensers
on the beaches to ensure people can
clean up after themselves around the
coast so they can easily access bags
for themselves the dispensers
are produced as it says they're by the
same company as
uh tex pack which we already have for
dog waste
and are supplied with biodegradable bags
initiated by the community and
crowdfunded
with a small contribution of 500 pound
from tdc
uh but hopefully this will
ensure that uh the installation of
promotion of this
will take place the focus is on the
community to keep the dispensers stopped
and to be actively involved in looking
after them
for sustainability rather than focus on
tdc
as our staff is limited and we expect
other groups to follow and wish to do
the same in other areas
which we will support next
slide please
as you can see there on the progress
update there are several
slides there and uh places that you can
access any links to our beach safety
booklet and
partnership um finally chair on this
um i i would like to
uh praise our staff
the agency staff that uh that we
took on board during the summer um
and that goes and that goes right from
the top to
the very bottom um
they were absolutely immense the
pressure on them was intense
and uh as going down
on the beaches of different beaches and
several times uh
during the summer to visit to visit them
and see the pressures
that they were under um
and i have to say i was very proud and i
think the council should be should be
proud of the work that they did in the
summer
and we look forward to to it being
better next
next year thank you chair okay
thank you steve um that was a very
comprehensive report
and very informative thank you members
if
any of you would like to raise any
points make any comments
ask any questions of council album
please indicate in the chat and i will
try and pick you up first council
campbell
uh thank you very much chair yes sir
thank you very much councillor alban was
an excellent
and uh inclusive uh report uh just like
to report that i was uh fortunate enough
as chair of ramsgate town council
to be included in the uh consultation
between all the stakeholders
uh on the management of ramsland
maintenance uh i'd like to congratulate
county district council for coordinating
the whole of these stakeholder teams
that uh
was mentioned in the actual report
together uh who worked collegiately
together
to produce uh in very difficult
circumstances a
uh an enjoyable uh summer period
although it was
completely overwhelmed in some areas it
was nice to know that it was mentioned
several times that ramsgate itself
turned council ramsgate main sands
was an exemplar of behaviour for the
visitors who came down
and produced no problems whatsoever
unlike the rougher areas of botany bay
stairs and somewhere in oregon
over that yeah we would like to
challenge you to a fight though
councillor campbell that's exactly true
i would like to compliment the creator
of the report for merging
three sometimes even four words together
to form one enormous long word
the same space yeah only actual report
i thought we got into german there's one
of the words some of the words were so
long
well done thank you all and thanks all
to the staff for actually creating and
coordinating
what was a very difficult time very well
done thank you very much
yeah absolutely second that council
campbell council again
keane you'd like to speak yeah thank you
um a few points seaweed was one of them
now i know
obviously there was lots of information
that did go out about this
but it's likely to be a problem again
next year as well
and i would like to suggest that there's
more proactive messages
because there was a lot of
misunderstanding by the public that
nothing was being done about
it and i know as i say that was
corrected but i think if if the messages
went out first
when seaweed starts building up as to
what's happening with it
that would help people last
year well last year earlier this year
sometime there was talk of
smart bins that know when they're full i
don't know if any of them
are in place yet and my third point was
the shellfish harvesting
again there was a lot of public disquiet
about
the amount of shellfish being removed
and
although sort of there was action taken
about that
can we do something again more
proactively next year
that's it uh yeah steve you'd like to
respond to that
yes thank you chair um yeah thanks
counselor keen
um the seaweed yes it was it it was
uh an issue obviously
uh the smell in birchington uh wasn't
very nice
and certainly the residents were totally
unhappy about that and i
i understand why um the problem that
arises uh from
uh one this the summer that we had
created and burst you know like a vast a
vast amount of seaweed
that we haven't had for some
considerable period of time
we did put out the communications as to
as to
what what was happening um we did
coordinate with uh uh
members of uh elected members in
burstington um and we did talk to them
about
what could be done and actually what
what couldn't be done because i
i think the important part of this as
well is that the
uh is is that because of the area that
we're in and and the
the uh chalk is uh protected
so it's very difficult to get to gain
access
especially just to some of the coves to
be able to re
remove the seaweed effectively without
damaging
uh the infrastructure if you like um
so it is a difficult
um i'm certain it's one of the things
that that we will look at
to see whether we can manage that better
um
i'm all up for that um obviously because
it means less grief for me
and um i will take that i will take that
forward counselor keen
um the smartbeams we do have some around
the area
we haven't got a lot uh and and
uh we we try to maintain what we've what
what we've got because of cost we all
know the issues that we have in cost
and and thank you gavin so i just missed
that
then um let me just see what kevin's
just said he's probably giving me a
better thing now i can't confirm chair
we we
we you'll see in some of the other
districts
uh like uh canterbury and derby they
have these
litter bins which are the solar panel
compactor bins that we looked at but
the the cost is prohibited the cost is
about uh four thousand pound the bin
where we pay about three hundred
uh but we do we did uh put some uh bin
sensors in some of the large 1100 bins
that you see on the four shores
and they do alert the staff when they're
getting full so it did improve
uh operational efficiency over the the
summer period and obviously what we'll
do is
we'll assess that and then we'll see how
we can then use that going forward in
the future
[Music]
thank you i was just about to say that
chair
i'm sure this did it much more
eloquently
everybody says it more eloquent than i
do um
the shellfish um issue
that was raised quite quite early on in
the summer
and uh it was past about community
safety team and we did get out when it
when we were notified of of them there
and
and stopped them and took the necessary
action uh but again if you think that as
soon as we it's reported we
we we will deal deal with it
okay accounts for scott
hello good evening many thanks chair um
yeah excellent uh
presentation just a quick one i might
have just misheard but um in relation
to the cycling provisions for the
promenade um
when we say we've got uh sort of the
the lanes in the lanes or we talk about
the temporary stickers so we moved on to
being able to
do that sort of contentious issue with
the promenade
all right i can clarify that yeah yeah
the first
you might remember we we gave a briefing
to to all members
it was a free phase project and the
first phase was putting the floor
stickers
uh on and some signage uh the next stage
is obviously doing that split down the
the proms
and also putting some physical barriers
particularly where we've got no
cycling areas around some of the
concessions
around some of the uh beach huts as well
so that's our next phase
money has been given to kcc we're just
in the process of
submitting bids for access to some of
that money well okay
there's a clarification right thank you
okay
uh councillor whitehead um just put
something on chat
uh it it's not really within procedure
but it's as it's relevant
um i will uh allow you to speak on the
subject of the shellfish issue
uh in relation to safer communities so
councillor whitehead welcome to the
meeting and over to you
thank you very much chair that's really
kind of you um
yeah in relation to the shellfish issue
i
am aware that it's been brought up very
frequently on social media
i am aware that there have been frequent
reports of people collecting
a lot of the groups that have been
reported to be collecting
are families and they're sometimes two
or three people
and it's important to remember that they
are actually allowed to collect
within limits and that's coordinated by
ithka
and if people do have concerns in terms
of large groups collecting or very
significant amounts being collected
then it's right to report that but we
have had families filmed
we have had families treated very badly
actually um and we need to be very
careful that we are not damaging
the relations with particular
demographics here because
it's it's important to remember that
people are allowed to do this
and that they have the right to do that
without being filmed and without being
harassed
if they are working within limits and
it's something i think that's very
important to remember
and we need to as well think in terms of
what our history as an area is
it's
a coastal area historically
this area has been used to collect huge
amounts of shellfish this used to be
part of our economy
and people collecting small amounts of
shellfish for personal use
is not going to damage our ecosystem or
our structure significantly
and it definitely shouldn't be a reason
for people
to interfere with people doing things
that are perfectly legal
thank you okay thank you councillor
whitehead
councillor alban you'd like to come back
on that
yes chair thank you um totally agree
with what council white has said
in relation to uh families or people
like myself or
or you i've often see you down trying to
pick some wink wrinkles down not
on on a beach chair but so
certainly uh all the local families have
got their first council
album there's none left when i get there
i
i i think what's happened i think the
main problem was
that um early on in the summer there was
very large groups of people who come
down
uh and they were also when they were
taking when they were
collecting a shellfish they were also
uh cooking cooking the shellfish
uh it was in barnes car park in margate
and uh and and they were um
it was being done on a commercial basis
not on a private basis it was clear what
was what was happening
so it was those issues that we were
trying to try to stop
not general families who would just go
down and
and want to pick up a few cockles
muscles whatever it may be
thank you chair okay thanks steve i
can't see any other members indicating
but i've got a few questions and
comments steve
um firstly do we have uh any idea
now um how much extra we've had to spend
this summer with those uh extra measures
that you put in force
um is there any likelihood that there'll
be any recompense
coming from the government because i
think as you pointed out earlier i mean
one of the reasons for us having many
more people is
you know inability of people you know
not being allowed to travel abroad and
so on
uh and being encouraged to to come to
our beaches and
are there plans to provide similar
whatever it costs this year to provide a
similar budget
for 2021
you're muted steve can't hear you steve
steve you're muted uh sorry jeff
i think any of that muted myself yeah i
think
mr white might be able to give you the
uh
the the monetary issues i can come back
on the other stuff
okay yeah yeah thank you uh in terms of
the
the monetary uh aspect
uh we as you are aware as part of
uh recent budgeting settings is we did
allocate some additional money didn't we
from reserve for covid
and part of that was to pay for some of
this additional work
and we've also received some uh over a
million pounds
last week uh to contribute towards that
additional cost but that's additional
cost
across the whole of the council which
has been significant
uh i think we were we were caught on the
back foot just in general
i think the and we've gone to back to
government to say the
the prime minister making the
announcement that everybody should get
themselves to the seaside
without actually speaking to anybody
prior to that was a bit of an issue for
everybody
but i think from our point of view i
think we reacted extremely quickly in
terms of opening the public conveniences
uh one of the main issues we also had
was the rnlie
when the rnli initially approached us
and they're under contract they were
going to
just provide uh lifeguards on two of our
beaches
and normally we have them on to 10 of
our beaches and
with a bit of persuasion and negotiation
with us and we were the only council
that did it in the country we managed to
get up to seven although it didn't cover
all our blue flag beaches
additional costs i think unexpected were
the cost of the security
uh on the beaches which was to warn and
inform
and uh encourage people to keep social
distancing
i think council albums right is it was
disappointing that we had to put extra
security in
the toilets to protect the cleaners
because the cleaners
were getting harassed significantly by
members of the public
and uh we do have uh for the summer
period we do have a
an agency budget so we did use
we did manage that agency budget and
kept within that
issue it was just all the additional
peripheral uh
costs i think next year i think this
year it's been
really good with the partners we've
established a really good relationship
with all the partners
and i think moving forward we'll be
taking the beach management plan to the
next level next year
in terms of budget setting yeah we will
incorporate as many costs as we can in
in the
budget was moving forward into next year
thank you
steve you want to add something yeah i i
i just think
uh chair that um
what i wanted what i would like uh what
i would like the council
to do is to fund
uh the issues
that particularly concern our residents
uh and and uh most of that it comes from
uh whatever under operational services
whether it
be uh waste collections our street
sweeping
uh our car parking uh whatever it may be
and especially our beaches and the areas
and toilets and stuff like that
we need to be able to put the money in
to that so that we can operate
properly and and give our residents and
visitors
what they require now whether we will be
able to do that
in the with setting our our budget for
21
22 that will need to be seen
and work is already starting on that
chair so i can't really give you
an any answer on that okay thanks steve
steve uh in your presentation you
mentioned the pspo
i don't know what that may be a bit of
an update on that i mean is it actually
enforced how far does it cover you know
i can give you an update on on that
chair uh there's the public space
protection order for the
the dog walkers on the beaches and that
from the consultation at the moment
because that that
lapsed in end of last month so we'll be
looking at renewing that to put the
restrictions in
uh we do have a number of bylaws with
regards to bonfires
uh another activity alcohol etc on the
beaches although some of the beaches are
covered by existing powers
that the police have what we're
attempting to do
and uh might be a guinea pig for the
rest of the country is
turn some of those bylaws in into
a public space protection order so
that's the next
process because if we do it as a public
space protection order
we can use enforcement through the issue
of fixed penalty notices
to enforce the problem with the bylaws
is first you need to catch them secondly
you got to go through a protracted
enforcement activity get the evidence
etc
i mean for example the bylaws with
regards to cycling on the problems
uh we found out relates to a law that
goes back to the early 1800s
and isn't he's not really relevant to
people
traveling in you know extreme extremely
expensive bikes at high speed
but what we're hoping to do is we
incorporate those into the public space
protection order
and then have suitable enforcement
actually warning informing and then if
people are complying then we'll be in
the position like i said to issue
fixed penalty notices yeah thanks kevin
i mean you're right we have had problems
with
fast cyclists interrupting the progress
of sedan chairs
in king's gates um can i just touch on
the
uh security for a minute i think um take
a bit of credit
for broadstairs here i think we were the
first uh
place to introduce security um
and it was a an action because some of
the behavior was
getting quite desperate on particularly
viking bay
um one of the issues i think
that people had is that it's great that
simply people being in a uniform around
does seem to make a lot of people behave
better
but it did seem to fall down a little
bit
when it came to really needing to do
something because they have
so few powers i mean is there anything
that can be done about that i mean
i think there's a particular concern
about sort of
control of alcohol on the beaches are
there any things that can be done about
that at all
well i think as gavin's as uh gavin's
just
just said chair is that uh obviously uh
if we can get one of these orders uh the
the bylaws changed to be uh
one of these orders so we can have fixed
fixed penalty charges then we can deal
with it that way but at the end
the end of the day uh the
police have got a step forward um
you know we all know that they are
stretched um
and that they don't always respond it
depends how many officers they have on
calling the jews
in the area and uh and it is them that
we need to be able to
come down and to be able to take to take
some action
and as you quite rightly say uh chaired
the the
the enforcement officers of the um
security guards guys can uh
advise uh and and give them
some instructions what they shouldn't
what they shouldn't shouldn't do
but they can't actually do anything
apart from issue
issue a notice so um
but uh we just need to see
that's something that we need to look at
and take forward
chair as part of the as part of the
ongoing process of the beach action plan
and to see whether we can get anything
uh put in in
relation to when we do have some serious
issues
okay thank you steve um can i just touch
on
the old favorite of toilets yeah i mean
it was
particularly noticeable here that with
the botany bay hotel being closed the
lack of
that sort of toilet provision really put
pressure on on the public services
and it was great when you introduced
temporary toilets so
there's two questions really i suppose
um one is you know
are there plans for the temporary
toilets to be there again next year
um and indeed uh could there be any uh
sort of salvation to be found in some
kind of arrangement with
premises like pubs hotels bars and so on
near the seafront
that have toilets to actually be a bit
more amenable to
members of the public using them without
having to buy a drink
i think sheriff to take you to take the
last bit first
is that all across the island our our
officers have been
uh talking to businesses on our sea
fronts
uh in relation to allowing them to to
go in um but obviously at the start of
it until they were allowed to open again
that is where we had the problems and
the issues uh certainly places like
botany bay
um where we had some real serious issues
there
um it did take a
uh a while to get those uh to get the
portaloos in because of finance
again you know we had to scrabble around
to get the money to get those
in um so you know that
the officers had to juggle around the
finances to see what we could get in to
stop doing something
something something else so again i
think that's all part of the plan one of
the as soon as we came out of
after the summer but what i'd said to uh
gavin and madeline was that we need to
have a review of the whole of the summer
see what what we can do better and if
we've said during the beach management
plan
is that is taking place and that is an
ongoing an ongoing thing
so i'm hoping bob that we can actually
get
uh things like the portaloos at botany
bay
and other and other areas of course in
relation to
our um our fixed toilets
and we have issues with a lot of them
uh you know they're they're they're
they're old
uh they need a lot of work doing doing
to them
and we need to look again whether we've
got the finances
to do it and i personally think that we
should
have fewer but the ones that we do have
is to make them better
better for for our residents than our
visitors but of course
as you know you as you know as a former
leader of the council
toilets is one of the one of the things
that that people will
will will moan and groan about more than
anything
but as i've been saying you know talking
to
uh one of the uh my opposite
shadow cabinet member this morning was
that
he didn't know i certainly didn't know
until i was told
that the council doesn't have to provide
toilets
at all and uh and the general public
don't know that either
um but it's not something that i would
want to do is to close down all the
toilets i don't think that's the right
thing i think
as a seaside results that we should
maintain our toilets but we should
maintain fewer
but make them better so that we can get
rid of some
put that money back into the toilets
that we have and make and make them
better chair
yeah absolutely thank you steve thank
you i mean
thank you for your presentation and
thank you gavin as well
i mean just in passing i mean you made
reference to publicity and the fact that
um you and the leader had been on tv
that there had been signs put up on the
roads coming into phanet and certainly
when
they started putting up the signs saying
you know botany bay was full
we did notice that the pressure wasn't
quite as great on those days so it does
seem to work so
yeah i think there's lessons there for
the future definitely
so thank you very much for that thank
you gavin
okay thank you would you mind if i um if
i went off and
had a bite to each here is that okay
with you if you can tear yourself away
from the
proceeding steve then carry on
thank you very much jen thank you very
much members thank you thank you
cheers now okay
okay members moving on the agenda item
next is the gender item
five which is concerning foyer house
and i'll call upon ashley jackson to
introduce the report
actually council whitehead's doing it on
behalf of housing service
ah okay fair enough my piece of paper
says differently
but always counsellor whiteheads
pleasure to welcome you
again to our over your scrutiny panel so
over to you
right thank you very much chad here to
surprise as always
um so in relation to foy house
it's becoming ever more obvious that
housing is about more than simply
providing accommodation
houses are not simply buildings they are
homes
and in no area of accommodation is this
more important to be aware of than in
temporary accommodation
people come into temporary accommodation
for many reasons
living in temporary accommodation is an
experience that requires thought
and care from landlords to make stays as
positive as possible
our plans for foie house are our chance
to show what we are capable of as a
temporary accommodation provider
and a chance to bring yet more of our
housing service in-house
reducing costs and increasing our
control and management of the service
simultaneously
foie house has been purchased by thanet
district council for temporary
accommodation
our aim is to provide flexible secure
and well-planned temporary accommodation
to reduce stress for our residents and
increase our direct provision
and ensure that as few individuals as
families as possible are placed out of
area
this is a new and exciting provision for
us and we were determined to plan it
well
as we have not done this before we have
taken advice regarding layout and
fittings from professionals and
colleagues
across kent who are experts in the
provision of temporary accommodation
to ensure that we are providing the best
arrangement possible in this flagship
project
the new scheme will provide four two bed
flats and four one bed flips
this was planned to cover our key
demographics in terms of contemporary
accommodation
and also to provide a good mix of
households to promote cohesion within
the block
all our units are designed to maximize
space provide
essential facilities promote energy
efficient usage
and very importantly provide facilities
that specifically keep the needs of
households in temporary accommodation
in mind all units conform to the
nationally described space standards
to ensure that families are guaranteed
good size accommodation in their time of
need
all are heated electrically with
electric ovens and hobs to promote
energy efficiency
and we are looking at installing solar
panels to further improve energy
efficiency
and help resident families with their
energy costs
all have open plan living and dining
rooms to try and maximize the feeling of
space
at a time when families need considerate
use of space the most
all have access to the courtyard garden
and lift to increase accessibility
and very importantly families and
individuals who find themselves in need
of temporary accommodation
all have very good size storage
cupboards and access to a communal
laundry room
a bike store is also being provided to
tie in with our large
aims of helping communities to be as
active as possible
via our new developments
looking at the development floor by
floor gives us a good idea of the
overall plans
and why we have designed the development
this way
the basement of the development will be
used for meters and cctv
equipment and therefore will not be used
by residents
the ground floor contains one two bed
flat
one one bed flat again providing a good
mix of
households this floor with both side and
front access
also includes a management office for
easy access
also the bike store again for easy
access and the bin store
the first floor includes one two bed
flat and two one bed flats
again to provide a good mix
demographically and the planned area for
the laundrette to maximize access for
all flats
the second floor includes one one bed
flat and two two bed flats
and provides maintenance access to the
roof
we aim to submit planning following this
meeting if approved
internal strip out is due to take place
in january 2021
with work starting on the development in
april 2021
we are planning to complete in early
2022.
consultation as always is key to a
successful development
we are keen to work with residents and
businesses in the area
and we will be writing to them shortly
to advise them of our designs
and also to ask them for their opinion
on the external finish of the building
our design team have already produced
several options and we will conduct a
poll within the local community to find
out the most favorable
foy house is yet another important step
towards our housing service becoming a
strong
centralized local provider it offers us
a chance to provide high quality
accommodation
for families in difficult situations
under our protection as their landlord
we have a duty to protect families
and residents especially when they are
at their most vulnerable
and tenants have a right to high quality
well-planned accommodation
regardless of the permanence of their
residency
our plan to avoid housed and help us
achieve both our responsibilities and
our aims and i look forward to hearing
your views
thank you very much chair okay members
any comments questions
casa campbell
oh yes thank you chair uh thank you very
much uh councillor whitehead
uh mine isn't so much about the
provision of four house it's about the
usage of four house
um given the uh uh the great need for
temporary accommodation how are you
going to select
uh those families that actually require
it is there going to be a limit
on the time that this temporary
accommodation can be
actually used by any particular family
um those are the two questions i'd like
to ask thank you
obviously any residency is always in
line with our allocations policy
and we do have particular limits that we
stick to in terms of temporary
accommodation
um but in relation to this residency in
particular i'll refer to
ashley jackson if that's okay to see
what's planned specifically in terms of
the allocations
fine actually yes so um obviously uh
we never know who's gonna approach us
homeless we just you know it's uh
kind of we're kind of going as as day by
day
there is no limit to the how long
they're there they're there until we get
suitable alternative accommodation
um and obviously we don't know when that
will be at all
so um it's quite hard to give a time
time scale i'm afraid
on that just to follow up chair is that
okay
yeah carry on yeah uh yeah are you my
point really would be are you going to
concentrate mainly
uh on this template accommodation with
uh families with young children
uh rather than sort of just adults i
mean this is a sort of one of the
criteria what criteria are you going to
apply
uh to determine uh the usage of this
particular facility
should i answer that councillor
whitehead
yeah surely so um obviously the the size
of the accommodation dictates who we
um allocate their spaces to so we have
four one bed flats and four two bed
flats
we can't we could only put um for
example two adults and one child
in the two bed units and obviously
single people
we would never over um over accommodate
the unit so that
that dictates who goes in really it'll
be
single people with one or two children
okay could i just ask a follow-up on
that um
these obviously are going to be very
nice units when they're done
um and you've said that it might be sort
of difficult to move people on i mean is
there a possibility that these
this will simply become a kind of
apartment block of eight units that are
permanently occupied
no it has to be temporary accommodation
so they will they will get move on
accommodation from there just it's just
impossible to say when that is
but it is specifically temporary
accommodation
so it could be one it could be six
months you know it's really hard to say
sure okay thank you for that council
roper you wanted to make
comment or ask a question
yes um thank you um thank you chair
first of all i think i just looked at
the plans as well
they look brilliant they look very well
laid out
and uh whoever moves in there should be
very grateful i hope
in fact i think it's it's such a good
idea that i wonder if
i'm particularly bearing in mind that
covert has probably thrown up a lot more
homeless people because
of financial pressures um are there any
other sites or any other plans to
develop this further thank you
i can speak in terms of what i would
like
um obviously i
am very very keen on housing
being in-house entirely i think it gives
us
a greater degree of control i think it
gives us
a greater sense of security for our
residents
and as much as i appreciate fully the
partners that we work with
i do
i do believe that we stand to make a
significant difference
to the lives of the residents that we
manage to house
in this block i would like very much to
be able to extend that
but that does always depend to a large
degree
on funding and what we can actually do
with that and what mhcrg propose
and are willing to provide funds for
um this is
a new venture for us um in terms of
providing temporary accommodation
i think it will work very well um i'm
in fact i'm pretty certain it will work
very well
um and i think a lot of the proof of
that will come
within the project um but i'd like to
hand over to
um ashley in terms of yeah what they are
planning
long term okay so um we
have a phase four development which has
just been approved by
um cabernet which includes a program of
acquisitions
and um a program of development now that
development at the moment
is um for general needs housing so um
for our households off the register um
at the moment we don't have anything
within our budgets for
uh another temporary accommodation block
okay thank you cass campbell you wanted
to come back
uh yeah thank you just a quickie really
um
my if my memory serves me right and
probably doesn't
uh there used to be a three-year
residency rule to apply for social
housing
to go on the social housing register um
if that's the case
uh will this three-year residency rule
apply to this temporary accommodation
uh criteria when they families come
forward
to apply for temporary accommodation
um i'll handle ashley
in that case we do have residency
criteria
in terms of accommodation um
barring certain exclusions um but
in reference to this block i think it's
best with ashley yeah
i'm not 100 on that i'm afraid um
obviously
we would only um allocate those units
to households that were um eligible
so um for temporary accommodation
is that yes or no i don't know i
housing options manager okay
um could i ask a question um the report
says that
there's a 1.63 million capital scheme
does that actually include the
acquisition cost of the building
yes okay thank you
thank you members any other any other
comments any other questions from
anybody
can't see anybody
i think we've got perhaps yeah sorry
sorry councillor huxley hi chair um
thanks i think councillor boyd wanted to
speak as well actually she was with yeah
she's gone she's just gone on the list
okay
um thanks just to say um our visitors
allowed
councillor whitehead at the um will be
allowed will they at foye house
or is it going to because it's got like
a office and obviously there'll be staff
on site all the time
um what happens there thanks
as far as i'm aware visitors will be
allowed um
it's simply to allow families a greater
degree of
security in terms of having a touch
point
um as far as i'm aware but have you
turned over to ashley for
more details absolutely um obviously not
overnight visitors
um but yes yeah vistas would be allowed
and there is a management office where
a member of our staff will be in there
so they'll be obviously you know
they'll be checking people in and out or
you know that kind of thing anyway
because of security so yeah physicists
will be allowed
okay counselor boyd
thank you um it's more of a comment and
i think you kind of answered part of my
question earlier
um but with regards to the design
whether it be thought around sort of
where you say it's two bedrooms
does that mean that both bedrooms can
accommodate either a double bed or two
single beds or does that mean that the
second bedroom will only accommodate one
single bed
could we look at perhaps there
particularly you've got a family with
two siblings um it's just more of a
comment around
what's that space and how can it be best
utilized and in order to
house people with several children
otherwise just the one child yeah
counselor whitehead i can comment on
that
so the two bedroom units are four person
units so that could be one person with
three children
so yes you know we'd look at um
maximizing it
as we could okay uh members anybody else
wish to make a comment
i can't see anybody uh thank you can i
thank you ashley
and again uh council whitehead for
coming along tonight and
for uh explaining everything in in such
clarity and detail thank you very much
indeed
thank you thank you for having me very
much thank you
okay members moving on um agenda item
six review of the isp
work program um i've not seen him around
but i
thought that councillor reverend piper
was coming along to
uh make some comment are you are you
there counselor piper
yeah i'm here chair thank you okay
um like members cass piper is here
you may remember we set up a memorial's
working party to
look at the issues that arose following
the problems over the uncle mac
plaque in broadstairs that working party
has had its first meeting
elected councillor piper as chair and
i've invited council piper along tonight
to summarise uh process
progress so far and indeed next steps so
council piper over to you
thank you very much chair for the
invitation to report uh clearly
these are contentious matters and there
are widely differing views
um around members of the public um
for the report the working party forgive
me i'm looking at a different screen
because i can't see the little
words on the small screen the working
party was asked to consider
an appropriate response to matters
recently raised regarding
memorials around the district our task
is to formulate and recommend to this
committee mr chairman
and to the executive and here i quote a
draft system
process or criteria for reviewing
memorials for example statues plaques
road names and similar matters to help
determine whether
if requested a decision should be taken
to either
remove them or carry out some other act
unquote the working group held its
inaugural meeting on wednesday the 30th
of september 2020
and considered the nature of the work it
had been set
the minutes of that meeting have been
published
and i would encourage all interested
parties
including members of the public to
familiarize themselves
with the contents for this meeting mr
chairman i'd just like to highlight
a couple of key issues arising from the
meeting we held
it was agreed that this is a difficult
and a sensitive matter
and it would be helpful to receive
representations from groups which
represented persons with characteristics
which were protected by the equality act
of 2010 there are mr chairman
and the details of this are not on the
public minutes i only mention that
because i have in the last day or so
being contacted
by members of the public asking why
things have not been included there are
good reasons for that but their arms to
chairman almost
a hundred memorials alone around
our district so it was also agreed that
the council does not have the resources
to individually review
all such memorials so the council will
respond
on a reactive rather than a proactive
basis
mr howes has contacted the groups and
individuals suggested by councillor
aaron roth
and councillor becky wing asking them to
provide
written representations on the process
for considering memorials
and he has invited them to attend the
next meeting of the working party
in person when responses have been
received
we will be able to hold another meeting
to consider these contributions
and make further progress all requests
for a review of a particular memorial
etc
would be considered against the public
sector equality duty
however the judgment of the decision
makers should
be fully informed as widely as possible
as the chairman i'd like to thank the
working party members for their
participation and the guests who came
on that meeting and mr charles hungway
for his administrative support
and mr tim howes for his analysis and
guidance
particularly the ongoing guidance which
will be regarding the public sector
equality duty that concludes the report
for now mr chairman i am happy to copy
it
to all members of this committee if you
feel that would be
appropriate that will be useful uh
council piper thank you very much
and thank you for your presentation
council campbell you wanted to make a
comment
and i apologize uh chair now i want to
speak mainly on the
work program so i'll leave other members
to ask questions of councillor piper's
report
and i'll come in thank you very much
okay council hopkinson
thank you chair um thank you for that
report i was just uh
interested you mentioned that groups
have been uh contacted i
wonder i don't if you've got the the
group's uh
their accounts the piper i don't know if
it's prohibitively long i wonder if you
could tell us who's been contacted
well i i don't have you the screen open
just give me one second
we actually had a guest speaker who came
to the first meeting
and she has been contacted and it was
suggested if you'll give me one second
to open the screen
um it was suggested that
we contact just wait for it to open
uh mr chris nichols was one of the
people
we were asked to contact
um from an organization called calling
time on racism um i can't share the
details of the response we've had yet
but
in his response he has mentioned one or
two other groups that we might also
make contact with but that'll be for
discussion with the
working party the next time we meet
thank you thank you
any other comments members
no okay counselor piper thank you very
much for that and if you could circulate
your report that would be very good
thank you
thank you thank you council campbell you
want to talk on the
uh work programme uh yes thank you very
much chair
i'd just like to remind members if they
haven't seen it that i sent an email
around
um about three days ago urging members
or
soliciting members to support my uh uh
calling
for the uh cabinet decision on ramsgate
market
three so far councillor campbell you've
had three of you well i think it needs
five
for more one for more than one group
doesn't it to call it in
something like that or the chairman to
look on you kindly
the chair to look at me kindly i don't
think it will be a very long
uh and detailed uh overview and scrutiny
initial meeting
uh to seek for the cabinet to amend
their
recommendation uh the uh the reasons why
i've called in are contained within
uh the actual uh email so if members are
minded to
uh to call in um it's it's a very
important uh
retail offer uh an iconic market within
ramsgate
and i think it's only fair and proper
that uh elected members particularly
those members from ramsgate
and others as well get the opportunity
to input
to the terms and conditions to head of
terms
and also the decision making as to whom
would run the market how it be run and
where it would be run
so i urge members to support it if you
can and send an email to the chair
by the 30th of this month thank you very
much
okay nick could i bring you in at this
point
um would it be in order if members
tonight if there is a consensus to call
that item in
that you could take that as instruction
to do that or do you need us to go
through the process of receiving emails
sorry yeah we would need that in writing
i'm afraid sorry about that so if
members do want to then obviously just
drop you an email and if you've got your
five um then obviously just let us know
and we will
convince the call-in procedure okay well
you heard that members
uh councillor campbell is looking for
your support there if you could do that
that would be really good
thank you um i'd like to to raise a
couple of points on on the work program
um the first is that uh and i probably
should have
uh given you some warning of this um i'd
be quite interested in members comments
on whether the ranking of the
various projects that were suggested for
scrutiny
whether as a group we we actually agree
with that
or whether there are any items that
maybe we feel should be pushed up
uh the order of priority so that that's
one thing
um but there's a couple of things again
i i wondered if we could
uh consider um i think that it would be
quite
useful and uh timely for us to
try and look at some of the impacts that
covert has had on the district
particularly in relation to the impact
on businesses
and perhaps even more so on the impact
of
people who already are either in poverty
or close to it
and uh i wonder if members might
actually be minded to
support uh the notion that we could
bring that to scrutiny fairly quickly
i'd be interested in comments on that
our china council campbell yeah yes
that's fully support that i think it's a
very worthy uh suggestion you made there
the impact on employment
lack of employment unemployment is what
i'm talking about really for the world
i'm looking for
yeah um and the impact that has on on
family life and uh also the closure
and i think that also the issue as well
is that kovit is gradually sweeping
through kent
uh and suddenly as well and the numbers
of
infections in saneter rising
exponentially um
and we may find ourselves not in tier
one but tier two or hopefully not tier
three
in the not too distant future so i think
it's a very important issue and i fully
support your suggestion
okay um i'm seeing some kind of
agreement
um could i just have a sort of show of
hands
from members that would think it's a
good idea for us to pursue that
um that looks pretty unanimous to me uh
so
nick could we could we take that on
board and build that into
um hopefully that maybe the next um osp
meeting yeah yeah
more chairman yeah thank you okay i mean
i think that's really important and i
think that that
you know now becomes a priority but i
could ask that perhaps between now and
the next meeting members do have a look
at that
list of projects that we suggested
before uh
and have a look and see whether we still
think the
order on there is appropriate whether we
want to move anything up or down
uh the members have any other comments
they want to make on the work program or
nick have you got any comment you wish
to make
sure can i just get some information
um about this particular covid
suggestion you come up with which is a
very good idea
is there a particular cabinet member who
has who has responsibility for this
particular field
or is it spread amongst various cabinet
members
depending upon how it impacts upon their
portfolio
i would have thought it goes across the
board and and
you know knowing the way things work
around here probably the buck stops with
the leader
um get him here next time
i used
[Music]
so any comment and are you happy with
that
yeah we can uh we can certainly invite
him along that's no problem at all
um i think there was a councillor wants
to make yeah i've noticed that council
rugby got a question
there's a few points i would like to
make after everybody else has had a
chance
okay no problem council roper yeah thank
you chair
um i may be preempting this a little bit
but uh
i wonder if um brexit might have a bit
of an impact on local businesses as well
so if we're reviewing covid perhaps we
could
you know at least have a um an ear open
as to what's happening with brexit and
try and forestall any uh serious
problems thank you
um i think that's something we couldn't
possibly look at and
uh maybe um get somebody like uh mr
white along to just give us a very
uh quick update um and we certainly
should be looking at that but
i do think that the covert thing
probably takes priority so i think it's
a
it's a yes but let's see how we do with
the other one council
that's okay with you
okay thank you chair yeah okay thank you
uh nick you wanted to make some general
comments
uh yeah it was just purely um uh just to
uh refresh members
members uh memories uh the list that
counselor
um bayfield is is referring to is on
page 27
of this uh this meetings agenda and x2
you can see that the number one uh
item that came out of it was coastal
waste clearance followed by
uh replacement bins for litter and dog
waste with
uh to do empty properties and
uh what was it
um there was one other sorry oh managing
uh anti-social behavior on that beaches
so members in their thinking
towards next meeting may consider well
actually those three
three of those things seem to be all
sort of quite similar to each other and
as to whether or not they feel that
actually
if we wanted to do a a scrutiny review
after the work of the um
uh memorial's working party is complete
then uh then maybe that would be
something that the panel could
uh look at at recommending at the next
meeting
um with regards to i know that it's uh
been mentioned before but
uh unfortunately hannah's had to to
but it's just to confirm that um the
corporate performance
uh report that the members i'm sure will
remember uh the panel considering
uh at certain points throughout the year
uh there will be
we will be reporting on quarter one and
quarter two performance
at the january overview scrutiny meeting
um and also um they'll at that same
meeting will be presenting
a proposal for a new performance
management approach
so hopefully that should make everything
a lot easier for members to look at
going forwards into 2021
yeah i mean i think that's very good
nick because i
believe it was a meeting an earlier
meeting of the osp
that actually suggested that the
measures that we were using for
performance management weren't really
appropriate
and i think we were pretty unanimous in
saying that they needed reviewing so um
i won't say better late than never it's
great that they're coming forward and
i'm sure they'll be well received and
members will have quite a lot of
thoughts about that um so thank you for
that
um agenda item 7 is the forward plan and
exempt cabinet report list
for october to march uh unless members
particularly want to discuss anything on
that point
um i will note take that as noted
and i will close the meeting and thank
officers and members for your attendance
thank you very much i look forward to
seeing you next time thank you all
bye-bye